[Applause]
Barbie land is perfect and everything in
it is perfect and you have perfect day
after perfect day until you don't in a
way Barbie land is a world without aging
it's a world without death it's a world
without mistakes walking into those
environments and feeling the kind of
artistry and the love and the
playfulness it was so exciting it's just
eye candy and it's so fun to look at but
it's also beautiful genuinely beautiful
and they're such craftsmanship and such
Artistry in all of it I felt like I was
a miniature little doll in the real
dream houses one of the wonderful things
about shooting here on all these big
sound stages that we were able to really
create that world the fact that all of
this is practical and has been built
does a lot for the cast walking on and
saying well this is really the world
this isn't like any cul-de-sac that I've
ever been on it's very very pink it's a
little bit more pink than I've ever seen
in my life but I love metallic glittery
and sparkly it is I didn't really why so
many shades of pink existed in the world
but everything is beautiful and
everything looks perfectly plastic and
perfectly fake
foreign
it's all true to its own universe and so
distinct from The Real World we had a
vision of old filmmaking techniques and
as reference points we watched a lot of
old movie musicals I love the sort of
interiority of those musicals and how
they are authentically artificial that
they have this heightened emotionality
that comes from its artificiality Greta
calling the term authentically
artificial that it feels like an
authentic world with its own rules but
these people are authentic and they're
feeling real things I'm such a huge fan
of Greta's in her work she's so smart
and deep in everything she does so
everything from the script to the sets
to the Wardrobe to the props she is one
of a kind and it's such a singular
Vision which she's created she's just
the best I love her so much she is one
of the very few authors of Our
Generation and it's why I wanted to work
with it Greta's enthusiasm is just
completely contagious and when she
started describing these ideas that I
read on the script that the way she
described them to me was just wonderful
a big part of it was making sure that I
didn't let the adult part of my brain
take over and run the show that I was
like what did the little girl want
iridescent purple and brighter brighter
pink
pink is a major major part of the design
we tweaked and created this look of
table and then everybody could choose or
adapt colors to make sure that they look
pleasing and indeed the colors look
beautiful a lot of it was inspired by
old slim Aarons pictures and that 1970s
Palm Springs sort of kind of vibe of
leisure and clean line
beautiful people in beautiful places
doing beautiful things that was the
Mantra that's the essence of Barbie toy
was a big aspect to the design Greta
always said when people to watch this
and feel like they can reach in and
touch it or pick it up because that's
the world of Barbie and toys we are in a
giant toy box and this is the toy box
and this is the toy world and they are
dolls
welcome to Bobby's dream house come on
in
[Music]